foreign
good afternoon everybody happy Monday
okay
so before I introduce our special guest
today I wanted to address the
devastating earthquake in turkey and
Syria today our deepest condolences are
with those who have lost loved ones in a
devastating earthquakes that have thus
far claimed thousands of lives and
caused massive destruction in turkey and
Syria the president authorized an
immediate U.S response in addition to
the U.S Personnel currently on the
ground we are in the process of
deploying additional teams to support
Turkish search and rescue efforts and
address the needs of those injured and
displaced by the earthquakes U.S
supported humanitarian partners are also
responding to the destruction in Syria
since the earliest reports of an
earthquake last night Americans
officials have been working closely with
our NATO Ally turkey National Security
adviser Jake Sullivan reached out to his
counterpart last night
secretary Austin spoke and secretary
blinken have both spoken with their
counterparts today usaid is also
coordinating with their Turkish
counterparts on traditional assistance I
just wanted to let you know we just
found out that we anticipate the
president and president erdogan will
have an opportunity to speak very soon
and we will certainly have a readout
when that conversation occurs
finally I wanted to turn it over to our
special guest today National Economic
Council director Brian deese Brian
doesn't really need an introduction as
you all know given I told you all just
last week how much we will miss him when
he departs later this month to spend
more time with his family which we think
is an amazing thing for him and his
family and very happy for him I will
note that I've just learned we all just
learned that today will be his 11th
press briefing in front of all of you
and it is an important milestone for
many reasons including being our first
guest on the third day of this
Administration and sharing the podium
with BTS and you also made a pretty
funny joke that day I don't know if you
remember when BTS was here but anyway
but today Brian is here to preview the
economic themes in the president's State
of the Union Address tomorrow you should
have all received a fact sheet just
moments ago on those themes and as well
we will have a press call tomorrow to
preview another theme from the
president's state of the uni you Union
his Unity agenda you should have
received an invitation to that call also
a few minutes ago and you can all expect
additional fact sheets and excerpts
ahead of the president's remarks at 9 00
pm tomorrow so please keep your eye and
on your inbox for tomorrow and please
tune in tomorrow night at 9pm Eastern
Standard Time for the president's
address with that Brian
one of the many things I've appreciated
is how
you all keep us honest
including that day when I followed BTS I
really appreciated how many of you
reported at the precipitous decline in
viewership
when BTS moved out of the briefing room
and I took over to talk about economic
policies so
um so thanks
um I I just wanted to spend a little bit
of time as Karine said giving you a
preview and a sense of how the president
is going to address the economic
priorities and economic issues in the
state of the union and then happy to
take your questions
I think that the president is hoping to
do two things broadly when it comes to
the economy in the State of the Union
the first is to put the progress that we
have made economically into back into
the broader frame
that really compelled him to run for
president in the first place and the
broader frame around what it actually
means to pursue what he refers to as a
bottom out middle middle out bottom out
middle out bottom-up economic strategy
and make a clear contrast to the
trickle-down economic philosophy that
has pervaded thinking for uh years and
decades in the past and so you will hear
him talk about the progress that we have
made but in that context that this is
this is it has been an animating part of
what the president has wanted to achieve
as president and also a real consistent
Vision that from the campaign to the
early days to ongoing even as we have
dealt with a variety of unexpected
issues that we have had to work through
the president has had a vision about
what it could actually mean to grow the
bot the economy from the bottom up
and you can you will hear about that now
the uh the Striking labor market report
that we got on Friday obviously
punctuated a historically strong uh
period in the labor market recovery uh
you all know the statistics the fact
that the unemployment rate is the lowest
it's been in 53 years
bottom up nature of the economic
recovery is often lost or best seen in
lesser understood statistics and so
things like the fact that we have seen
this historic burst in people creating
new firms people creating new businesses
coming out of the pandemic is not only a
source of Hope because people don't do
that if they don't think there's
opportunity in the economy going forward
but a huge source of potential dynamism
for our economy that we need to make
sure that we don't fall back into a
pre-pandemic equilibrium of low growth
low wage increases increased inequality
but also the historically Equitable
nature of this labor market recovery is
something that again connects to this
idea that the president has always
centered on which is putting workers and
families at the center of his economic
policy
so it's not just that we've seen the
labor market improve this quickly it's
not just that we've seen household
balance sheets come out of a crisis in a
stronger position than any modern prior
recovery
but also the Equitable nature of that
and I just to give you one example of
that if you look back historically over
the last several recoveries it's taken
on average 50 months for the black
unemployment rate to return to its
pre-pandemic level
um that happened in this recovery in 24
months less than half the amount of time
and that record is true if you look
across other demographic uh categories
as well
so you'll hear that about the president
sort of trying to put in context at the
progress that we have made
but the second thing just to speak to
the work yet to come and the president
uniquely understands that we have a lot
more work to do when it comes to the
economy and that even as we've seen real
progress and inflation coming down uh
over the last six months in particular
we have more work to do to bring prices
down at lower costs and create some
breathing room as he says for American
families even as we've passed historic
legislation
uh that will invest in America and help
bring Economic Opportunity back to
places across this country we have a lot
of work to do to actually Implement and
demonstrate that that kind of investment
can unlock Economic Opportunity in ways
that we're beginning to see all across
the country uh but we have a lot of that
ahead of us
and we have additional work to do to
demonstrate that we can do all of this
while being fiscally responsible and
while reducing the deficit something the
president has demonstrated in practice
over the last two years and that the
plan that he will outline in the new
policies that he will call for
will underscore that we can invest in
our country lower cost for families and
reduce the deficit all at the same time
last thing um which is something that is
is familiar to you all because he's been
saying it since he was a candidate and
as soon as he came into office is he is
going to continue to look for every
opportunity when it comes to the economy
and economic policy to reach out and
work with Democrats and Republicans find
practical paths forward find find
compromise it's something that a lot of
people wrote off and I think we've he
has and we have been able to demonstrate
that we can make progress on even when
people are skeptical of that but at the
same time he'll draw some clear lines of
things where he's not prepared to do and
and uh and we'll have we will have to
see whether his commitment to work with
Republicans with the Republicans are
prepared to step up and work with him on
a number of Economic Policy issues so I
think that's in Broad Strokes what you
can expect to hear from him tomorrow
night when it comes to the economy and
with that I'm happy to take a couple of
questions
[Music]
uh Brian congratulations on your tenure
on inflation specifically a lot of
progress has been made and you guys have
decided with Statistics but a lot of
Americans still aren't feeling it Poland
shows that as well what kind of message
can President Biden give tomorrow night
that
also
gets to the people who feel like yeah
inflation is still really biting yeah I
think the core message is we have to
make more progress but people should
feel optimism that because of what we
have seen and because the progress that
we've made that we know how to keep
making progress going forward so it as
you said we really we we have made a lot
of progress inflation is down now uh for
six months in a row
obviously a big piece of that is that
gas prices have come down and are down
by more than a dollar and a half from
the summer but we're seeing uh inflation
moderate in a variety of other
categories as well
and so
um at the end of the day this is about
can uh you know families and workers
look and say can I make everything add
up uh at the end of the month and so we
need to keep making progress in bringing
those price increases moderating but we
also need to keep making progress at
lowering costs directly for families and
so that's one thing you're going to hear
directly from the president that a core
part of any viable economic strategy
needs to answer the question of how are
you going to keep lowering costs for
families the president will outline
specific ideas on how to do that
including building on the prescription
drug reforms that we were able to enact
to give more people uh the relief from
prescription drugs building on proposals
that we have put in place to for example
lower the cost of child care lower the
cost of care for caring for an elderly
parent so that that also reduces a
family's balance sheet challenges but
also can help more parents more women
work those are the kinds of policies
that would actually help to continue the
progress that we have seen he'll outline
those and he'll make clear that you know
that should be our priority is looking
at how do we keep this progress going
here uh whatever you are pursuing both
White House can you talk a little bit
about uh how the debt limit will figure
into the president's remarks uh tomorrow
and is that a critical component of the
president's economic message sure
well I think that what you'll hear from
the president and what um is definitely
is is his perspective is that
um the full faith and credit of the
United States this Bedrock idea that the
president that the United States has met
all of its Financial Obligations for its
existence as a country
isn't something that anybody should be
using as a bargaining chip it's not a
negotiable item it's congress's
constitutional obligation and that's how
everybody should look at it not only
because it's a Bedrock of American
stability uh it's something that our
adversaries would look at and say if
that was questioned that might weaken
the United States but also because The
Economic Consequences of even
questioning uh that Bedrock principle
can be quite severe
so you'll hear that clearly from the
president and you will hear an openness
and in fact an eagerness to have a real
serious conversation about the fiscal
and economic priorities of the country
and where we can find common ground on
things like lowering costs for families
on things like how do we keep investing
in the country and creating more
manufacturing jobs and do that in a way
that reduces the deficit and the
president is going to lay out a very
clear and detailed plan his his approach
for how to do that he's eager to see
other plans and then we can have a
conversation about that that's the kind
of conversation you have in a normal
budget process and that's the
appropriate way to approach these things
thanks Brian um
a few minutes ago in your response to
Jeff you said the American people should
feel optimistic about the direction of
the country uh survey after survey shows
they don't and maybe survey over the
weekend should uh three quarters of
Americans view the direction of the
county and is attending the economy
taking the wrong direction is that an
objective for the president tomorrow
night to sort of convince the American
public that their views of the economy
are not the way you know that they
should be seeing things the way you are
and not the way they are currently doing
right now
I I think the objective uh as is always
the case for the president is to number
one uh meet the American people where
they are
um with a recognition as I mentioned
that uh that the anxiety and the ongoing
challenges that families feel in their
lives are
um the reality of a very challenging
period with a pandemic and a um uh and a
uh a a war in Europe that has driven
that drove gas prices up and food prices
up and created a lot a lot of
uncertainty
um and so first and foremost to meet the
American people where they are
um but also to help explain why he is
optimistic that if we continue to make
the kind of progress that we have
historic progress even with all of the
uh the distance that we have yet to
travel
then more and more families more and
more communities are going to see
Economic Opportunity and more durable
Economic Opportunity as a result of the
policies that we have put in place as a
result of the economic progress that
we're making so that's the way that the
president has always approached these
things but we'll approach it tomorrow is
to is to acknowledge and meet the
American people where they are but also
to try to tell a story about where we
are going where we can go together and
it you know it it is the case that if
you go around the world if you talk to
heads of state see heads of state CEOs
other leaders
they will tell you you know that the
United States really is better
positioned than almost any other country
that the the opportunity to invest in
the United States is so many people are
enthusiastic about and that bodes very
well for the economy not only in the
very short term but over the medium term
as well
thank you thanks Brian and I'll give up
to you to move here um so related to
that Jeff science was brought in in
large part to be the you know to
implement a lot of the uh
pieces of legislation that were signed
into law so I wonder if you could give
us a timeline for when you think
Americans really feel the impact of
chips of you know Ira of infrastructure
how long is it going to take before
those policies really make a difference
in the economy and then secondly at the
top of your memo
um before the McCarthy meeting you wrote
two questions that you really wanted him
to answer that the president was going
to pose to him can you tell us if you
got those answers about the uh well when
will they release their budget and will
he commit to the Bedrock principle that
the U.S won't perform instead yeah yeah
well so let me let me let me take the
first question first and so the first
question is is we are beginning to see
the impact all across the country
and I think that part of the reason why
we have seen economic projections over
the second half of last year
defy many people's in many more
skeptical observers projections we saw
political outcomes to find a lot of
people's projections as well is that
we're beginning to see that but on all
three of the major pieces of legislation
on infrastructure chips and Science and
on the inflation reduction act 2023 is
the year in which the most significant
impact will begin to occur and so you
know these things operate in stages and
so you know if you live in a community
like the greater Syracuse Community in
Upstate New York or outside in the area
around Phoenix the announcement that
there is going to be a big investment in
building a facility for to to
manufacture semiconductors is the
beginning of a process that is going to
change and affect your community across
time beginning with significant new jobs
in construction and then over the course
of 12 or 18 months hiring engineers and
and facility operators and the like and
so that will happen across time but I
think that this is a year of action and
investment and implementation where
across those areas you're going to see
this unfold in more and more ways and
one of the things that we we often show
but we use for our own internal planning
as well is just a physical map of the
United States where you can see
increasingly the the commitments of
private companies making Investments the
grand announcements going in the ways in
which they're going to begin to unturn
and so so they will certainly happen
across time
I think you know I do expect that this
coming year will be a big year on that
front and the last thing that I'll say
is that you know this is this commitment
to invest in this country
in a way that we haven't really done for
decades is core to the president's
bottom-up economic philosophy that you
have to do that with speed and precision
you need to make sure people understand
how it's done but you also need to
recognize that if we're really going to
rebuild our infrastructure we're really
going to regain our uh our strategic
Edge in an area like semiconductors we
also have to be committed to doing it
over a multi-year period certainly
that's true of other countries what we
have been deferring that maintenance and
not doing that investment so so it's
also going to be something that we need
to commit to over time
oh right okay and so uh well what I
would say about the meeting itself is
that the that both the president and the
speaker had a constructive and Frank
exchange uh those were the president
clearly laid out his perspective on
those issues
um and I will say you know um we are uh
we continue to hope and expect that the
House Republicans will put out a budget
plan uh we'll bring forward a budget
resolution that is the way that the
process
works most effectively and it really is
important for the American people and
for everyone to see they plan in full
detail with numbers that uh that uh add
up and then just back to the first into
the earlier question
um this question of honoring the full
faith and credit of the United States
and and everybody who holds an office of
trust being clear that
the united states will honor those
obligations and will not default on its
debt is something the president will
continue to make clear and continue to
make clear that's his expectation of
anybody Republican Democrat who holds
the office
look at the State of the Union right now
in this moment listening to what you
have to say about the economy what would
you say is the state of the economy just
specifically drilling down on the
economy yeah well uh on Friday morning
when I was over with the president in
this in South Court he he
said this so I will just say what he
said on Friday which is that the state
of the economy is strong
uh and that you know you see that in the
lowest unemployment rate in 53 years you
see that in the most jobs created in the
last two years uh in our country's
history you see that in historic
progress in an equitable recovery you
see that in the wage growth that we have
seen being disproportionately going to
those in the lower half of the income
distribution and so even with all of the
distance we have to travel and the
understandable and important anxieties
that families still face and the need to
bring prices down further I think that
he feels and we all feel that we are we
have an economy that is resilient an
economy that has been through an
extraordinary amount and defied a lot of
the Skeptics expectations over the last
two years another question since um
police reform this renewed call for
police reform is supposed to be very
strong in the State of the Union Address
you've done the numbers have you
crunched numbers for this about the cost
of bad policing to this nation via
lawsuits be it deal day doj
investigations pattern and practice Etc
have you done the numbers crunching on
that would it actually cost the American
taxpayer with with these incidents that
continue to happen
I don't I don't have this I don't have a
specific
um analysis to point you to but what I
would say
um is certainly it's the case that
um
funding the type of evidence-based
interventions that we know work uh in
communities across the country
generates is is both absolutely the the
thing we need to do as a country but
also has a broader economic dividend uh
as well
kind of yeah thanks uh Crane and
congratulations on the next step that
you're going to take so last week the
Federal Reserve chairman said that covet
is quote no longer playing an important
role in our economy is the president
going to make that pivot for policies
and what not going forward
[Music]
well I think you've heard I mean you've
heard from the president you've heard
from this Administration that because of
the progress that we have made on uh
covid uh it no longer is
um holding back
um our economy uh and the lives of the
American people in ways that it was you
know in fundamentally debilitating ways
uh two years ago when three days into
the administration when uh when uh when
I came to this uh podium
um
the reason why we're in that place is in
no small part because this President and
members of Congress work together to
prioritize putting the historic strategy
in place to actually get the country
vaccinated and make workplaces safe for
people to return and so I think the fact
that we are where we are right now is a
testament to the hard work of actually
prioritizing getting and a plan to
um to get the the pandemic under control
and certainly I think our policies
reflect that including the announcement
about how to responsibly wind down the
uh the um the pandemic emergency
Administration and the Department of
Justice is using that as the covid
hardship economic hardship as a reason
for student debt forgiveness so does
that policy then come off the table
no I think the the the legal and the
Practical justification for student debt
forgiveness is about the impact that
this pandemic has had on individuals
personal circumstances uh and certainly
those those impacts which have
accumulated over the course of the last
couple of years are profound they're
straightforward and I think that that
argument is uh that argument persists
even as we make progress through uh
getting to you know new stages of this
of this
um of this pandemic
uh thanks Brian another polling question
and I touched on it a little bit of some
of my colleagues questions you mentioned
how the president said Friday that the
state of the economy is strong we had a
poll out over the weekend ABC news that
found that 41 of Americans say they're
worse off financially now than before
this president took office how do you
explain the disconnect there of why this
administration's message about the
strong economy is not getting through
right so so I think I think the poll
that you just cited is actually
consistent so about two-thirds of
Americans say that their their
circumstances are better than uh uh than
before you say it either way
um and I think that uh that it is the
case that if you look at
the kind of key measures of basic
economic security do I have health
insurance do I have 400 in the bank in
case my car breaks down or I have
another emergency expense am I um late
or delinquent on a credit card bill am I
facing foreclosure if you look at all of
those measures
they um
on average American households are in a
better position than they were before
the pandemic hit and that's true for the
lower income uh quartiles as well and so
I think that that is in part reflected
in the day that you're saying is that
that more Americans believe they're in a
better economic uh position in terms of
Their Own uh balance sheet their own
family balance sheet and at the same
time in the way that we were talking
about before this has been a very
challenging period with uh with the
pandemic and all of the ways in which
the second and third order ways in which
that's affect our lives and the way that
we operate in the economy with the war
in Ukraine and the and the the cascading
impacts on Supply chains and on uh the
ways it affects things that you know the
the basic price of things that people
pay in the grocery store and so for all
those reasons it's uh it's
understandable that even as personal
household circumstances for the majority
of people have improved the anxiety that
the economic anxiety is real so I'd just
go back to the answer I gave before
which is why the president will both
speak directly to the fact that we have
more work to do
but also underscore
how the progress we have made to date
can paint a picture to move forward and
why we should then commit to the
proposition of seeing these policies in
this policy Vision through
okay I should basically yeah I mean
probably not that same question
um I guess when you've been asked
variations on this on the perceptions uh
voters are having in the economy but
when do people start feeling more
optimistically about the Outlook and
just to clarify on the the staff that
was just cited it's only 16 of those in
the pool poll believe uh they're
financially better off than when they
entered then when Biden entered the
office uh the White House and it's 42
fueled out the same so just to clarify
it's only 16 are feeling better off
yeah so what you're so what do people
start feeling more people start feeling
uh better off about the financial future
of the country
well look I think that um
I I don't want to you know I don't want
to repeat myself only to say
um we have more work to do
uh but if you look at the progress that
we have made particularly uh the recent
progress that we have made with
inflation coming down gas prices coming
down real wages as a result
going up and the labor market
opportunities that that come from a
strong historically strong job market
those are all reasons why we should we
should continue to continue down the
path of the progress that we have made
ultimately the ultimate uh you know the
the ultimate uh test of of an economic
policy and economic outcome is whether
families feel more Economic Security uh
in their lives and if you look at
numerous measures as we just discussed
we have come through this recovery
recovering people's Economic Security
historically fast and historically
Equitable and we have to keep making
progress on it
thank you
um the president has a lot of good news
to tout tomorrow low unemployment
reinvestment in manufacturing I'm
wondering though if you can help us get
a better sense of his thinking on a
lingering problem the other day when he
was asked about inflation
look the the core of what we've seen in
this economy has been a pandemic driven
economic crisis and a pandemic affected
recovery
um and that pandemic when he came here
was reaching out of control and there
was no strategy economic strategy
um to actually drive a recovery in the
economy and drive recovery in the
pandemic and I think that as we look
back
the um the principal drivers of
inflation have been the pandemic
globally and subsequent shocks to the
system the most significant of which was
uh the war in Ukraine uh and so
um that's where you know the the sort of
core drivers have been and that's
um as a result how we have oriented our
uh economic policies and I think that um
that Arc and next trajectory is one that
now being on the other side of it we are
making progress and and globally
um as inflation is a challenge
everywhere the United States is one of
the places where we're seeing one of the
strongest and most resilient labor
market recoveries with inflation coming
down as well so I think that that's the
um that's the historical context in
which uh the president was uh speaking
and certainly it's the context in which
we've been designing and implementing
our policies
thank you let me just go back to the
Friday jobs report Goldman as a reporter
today saying I think the odds of a
recession are falling next 12 months to
25 they now Peg the odds out from 35
percent
what do you think the odds are of a
recession right now and do you think
that they're improving given that jobs
data
okay more hopeful of a software look the
way I'll answer that question is is
um to go back to a point I made earlier
about the importance that this President
of this President having a consistent
and clear economic Vision
um we could go back you know seven eight
months ago when we laid out our strategy
for how to effectuate a transition to
more steady stable growth which meant
trying to bring inflation down maintain
a resilient and strong labor market a
lot of people at the time a lot of
projections at the time said that um
that wasn't possible that wasn't
feasible that the economy would likely
be in recession now you know in the
first quarter of this year and I think
that over the course of this period of
time we've seen uh we've seen inflation
come down we've seen the labor market
remain resilient we've seen real wages
uh go and and we find ourselves today in
an economy where we have real resilience
real resilience here and so
um as we look forward the the takeaway
that we take is less to look at the the
um you know uh the infinite predictions
that are out there though we study
um uh those analysis along along with
others and instead to redouble our
efforts to actually Implement a policy
agenda that we we know and we have seen
has really helped uh to bring this
progress along uh so so that's that's
where our focus is
[Music]
over the course of the last three months
it would be hard-pressed not to say that
the the economic data has come in in a
way that is uh spoke to inflation
Cooling and a more resilient labor
market than most people thought was
possible and a bit of a tricky question
they haven't obviously announced your
successor yet we don't know when that
will be one of the rumored candidates uh
has been the vice chair of the FED have
you been part of any conversations at
the White House about how that process
would go and replace it or filling any
fit candidacy and would existing
Governors be a candidate for the vice
chair would you be looking outside to
build a high strip position so the
president hasn't made a decision I'm not
going to speak to or get ahead of the
president making a decision on that
front so I'm going to leave that to him
thank you Brian and the Federal Reserve
increased rates and signals more rate
hikes is the president concern about
Rising borrowing costs for businesses
for consumers and how is this going to
impact his economic plan
well I think it goes uh it's an
important question and it connects to uh
just I'll bring it back to where you
know we started this briefing which is
the president's view is that the most
important things we can do for the
economy right now to sustain this
historic recovery transition to not only
a not only to get back to the
pre-pandemic equilibrium but to have an
equilibrium where we have stronger more
resilient growth higher productivity
gains
stronger and more broadly shared wage
gains is to actually invest in this
country and lower costs for families and
so that's particularly important at a
time where the financial pressures on
families and household balance sheets
are acute and to do that in a way that
is consistent with this transition that
we need to have and we have a policy
model for how to do that in fact the
inflation reduction Act was at its core
about lowering costs that families face
the actual you know monthly costs that
they face for prescription drugs or for
Health Care lowering the clean energy
costs that they face while also using
the deficit at the same time so we know
that we can do this we just we just
passed a historic piece of legislation
to this effect and so in areas from
Child Care to housing to otherwise
you'll hear proposals from the president
that have exactly that structure how do
we lower the costs on a family's balance
sheet and do it in a way that actually
supports the macroeconomic transition we
need
Brian
wondered
can we hear about it tomorrow night so I
think what you can expect to hear from
the president is his values and his
orientation on this issue which is he
thinks that it is
um
uh it is not something he would support
uh to cut either of those programs
and that there are ways that we can
strengthen those programs and actually
increase their
um the the ways in which they help the
American people while also uh bring down
the deficit at the same time so you can
certainly expect to hear from him a
pretty clear posture when it comes to
those programs specifics that address
the solvency question well I think that
the you know there's a there'll be a
period between the state of the union
and the budget and so I think you'll
hear from the president speaking about
his print his principles uh and his
vision uh tomorrow and then I think you
can expect that you're going to see a
lot of detail about the president's
policies uh in his budget
thanks in the speech will he directly
Express optimism of the U.S won't hit a
recession I said something he'll address
directly and then um on a separate issue
I think you're set to meet with the
French and German economic ministers uh
here tomorrow
um they're raising concerns about the
subsidies in the ira what's your message
to them going to be and what's the
latest in terms of how the U.S might
accommodate concerns
so in the first question I think you'll
hear the president is optimistic about
America's future because he believes in
the American worker and the grit and
resilience of the American people and
that that's that's a message that he
will he will communicate clearly and
with respect to your second question you
know our uh our messages is pretty clear
which is that Europe and other Allied
countries have nothing to fear from the
inflation reduction act in quite a bit
to gain and that when the United States
steps up and makes the most significant
investment in clean energy and energy
security ever in the history of the
country one of the many things that it
does uh is to actually
accelerate the reduction in cost of
deploying Next Generation Energy
Technologies that are critical for the
world and that those benefits are felt
far outside the United States number one
and number two we have uh nothing to
apologize and frankly everything to be
proud about that that is a piece of
legislation that provides long-term
technology neutral incentives to invest
in the United States and particularly in
communities that have borne the brunt of
uh of pollution or have been at the
front end of producing uh traditional
fossil energy that's the right thing to
do for the country it's the right thing
to do for our clean energy manufacturing
base it's the right thing to do for
American workers and the president's
quite uh proud of that approach so we'll
continue to work through those pieces
but I think the important piece is to
keep our eye on the fact that the United
States is now leading and other
like-minded countries should both
recognize that and also seek you know
opportunities to partner with us that's
certainly something we're open to
um putting aside the responsibility you
may bear for BTS taking a break shortly
after appearing with you everything it
was um it was it was shock yes it's a
correlation causation yeah I figured as
much
um but on a serious note a lot of the
optimism is based on the legislative
agenda that you guys signed into law
after the first two years but
implementation while it's kind of an
abstract concept also brings challenges
when you look into the months and years
ahead when it comes to implementing that
agenda what challenges do you think the
administration is going to have to
confront and how capable do you think
they are with the tools they currently
have to overcome any implementation
chapters yeah
well even the word implementation it
sort of sounds technocratic this really
is about investing in America because
it's about using public investment
grants or tax incentives to crowd in and
unlock an enormous amount of private
investment across the country
um and you're right the priority has to
be on doing that efficiently and
effectively and with uh with the policy
goals in the American people in mind uh
I think certainly it's going to require
as a country that we do things
differently to do business differently
it's one of the reasons why the
president has been so supportive of
Permitting reform and while we're
looking at the tools we have the
executive tools that we have to
accelerate uh the process we need to
demonstrate to the American people in
the world that we can build faster more
efficiently and more equitably than
we've done in the past
and while that's a challenge I feel
really quite confident and optimistic
that we have the tools in place Congress
has given us the tools in across those
three pieces of legislation we have
extraordinary talent and capability
across the executive branch and there's
been a lot of now because these laws
have passed a lot of mobilization
happening at the state and local level
with companies and otherwise organizing
around this Collective effort so no
question there will be challenges and
there will be setbacks along the way but
I think that that Collective effort of
investing in America I would just end on
the note of it also is it summons a
larger National project again one that
we you know we haven't really taken on
as a country since the 1960s around
collectively understanding the impact of
what it means to invest across years in
upgrading our infrastructure changing
the face of the country whether it's
electric vehicle charging stations or
whether it's being able to say you know
we committed to the proposition that we
were going to eliminate lead pipes from
schools and homes across the country and
then being able to see many years down
the road and that also creates the
opportunity for people to feel and we've
been talking you know about pulling this
sense of a pride in that in the United
States that we can do big things and we
can do big things collectively and that
um uh and that that's that's part of the
potential here
gentleman in the back you said do you
have any comments
thank you for taking so many questions
that we all appreciate that and we hope
your successor will too and we do really
appreciate it a number of them dealt
with his perception issue of how
Americans are feeling differently than a
lot of the positive data you have is
there a perception issue in the other
direction on inflation because when the
President says he's not responsible for
inflation that it's a global issue and
things like that is there a problem
um or or maybe a gap somewhere in how
the White House views inflation when so
many Americans feel it uh on a daily and
weekly basis when they're having to meet
their obligations is there a perception
gap on inflation here yeah no not at all
I mean you have a president who has gone
out and said that his top economic
priority is to bring down inflation you
have a president that prioritized
working with Congress to pass a bill
called the inflation reduction act which
as we talked about before was designed
specifically to lower the cost of
people's prescription drugs lower health
care costs lower clean energy costs and
you have a president that has been
tireless about working on those issues
that connect most directly to the lived
experience of people across the country
the efforts which I won't you know we've
talked about at this Podium around
trying to help bring gas prices down in
the wake of Putin's Invasion from things
very visible in public like the
historically strategic strategic
petroleum Reserve to things the
president is doing every day behind the
scenes diplomatically with our Allison
Partners on those sets of issues and as
a result in no small part because of
those efforts we're now seeing progress
that progress is not sufficient we need
to keep making more progress but the
president is actually focused today on
those uh those issues and that's what
you're going to hear how can we keep
making progress to reduce lower costs
for people and I would say this I think
also is an area of contrast that the
president will highlight which is that
um wait you know he wants this economic
conversation to focus on how we can keep
reducing costs for the American people
and doing things like cutting taxes for
the very wealthiest people in the
country and increasing the deficit as a
result of that
not only are bad Economic Policy but
they don't speak in any way to that core
issue so I think I think the president
is very much focused on that issue he's
shown that he can actually work to
deliver results and is going to keep
arguing why we need to make more
progress on that very last question uh
thank you uh speaker McCarthy clearly
believes Democrats in the white house
will give Republicans some concession
for raising the debt limit I'm wondering
why Democrats would negotiate it all
over over that debt ceiling
so I would just circle back I think I've
I've answered elements to this before
important to distinguish between two
things one is the Full Faith and Credit
of the United States government
and the sacrosanct nature of that
commitment and the core commitment that
the U.S needs to pay its bills and any
any sense that the United States is
going to fail to meet that obligation
has enormous economic and National
Security ramifications that no not we we
we cannot get close to
um separate from that issue
having a conversation about fiscal
policy having a conversation about how
we can reduce the deficit responsibly
while also keeping our focus on lowering
costs for families is something that the
president is uh is eager to have and
frankly the way to have that
conversation is for the president to put
out his budget plan
for House Republicans to put out their
budget plan and then to have a
conversation around those two so that's
why you've heard the president and the
administration uh both commit that we
will do that we'll put out a budget
we'll put out a very detailed budget
here in the next month and our hope and
expectation is that the House
Republicans will do the same
thank you all right
that's a good question
all right thank you so much and one more
thing before uh we head into questions
uh I also wanted to highlight that today
the vice president is convening private
sector leaders as part of the
public-private partnership she launched
in 2021 to address the root causes of
migration from Honduras Guatemala and El
Salvador the vice president is
announcing that this partnership has
generated more than 4.2 billion dollars
in private sector Investments these
Investments are created have are
creating Economic Opportunity for people
in those countries so that they are less
inclined to leave their homes and take
the dangerous Journey to the United
States these are long-term development
efforts but we are already seeing
encouraging Trends illegal border
crossing from Guatemala El Salvador and
Honduras have significantly declined
over the past 18 months this that's in
addition to the impact of the Border
enforcement measures President Biden
announced just last month which have
resulted in a dramatic decline in
illegal border crossing with Venezuela
Nicaragua Haiti and Cuba all told we are
now seeing the lowest number of illegal
Crossing between ports of Entry since
February of 2021.
it doesn't mean our work is done as you
all know we still have more work to do
and we're going to keep at it but unlike
republicans in Congress who simply pull
the political stunts and try to get in
the way we've got an actual plan to
address these very challenging issues
and as you see as I just laid out our
plan is indeed working all right go
ahead see you kick us off um
give an update on what the president
will be coming back from Camp David is
there a reason for his delay no I no no
update on when he's going to be
returning I think we had mentioned and
you probably saw his Twitter account
this weekend just laying out how on
social media how the president was uh
was going to Camp David to focus on his
speech for tomorrow night I just don't
have an update on his return and I'm
sure it'll be sometime this afternoon a
different topic uh in the wake of the
balloon operation
NSC and the administration said that
it's going to brief Administration uh on
that can you give us a list of which
Trump Administration members would be
eligible for that briefing in his former
president Trump eligible since the
president had previously blocked it from
getting you know classified briefings
after you left office so as we mentioned
and you heard my colleagues from the
from NSC that we are prepared the
intelligence committee is indeed
prepared to uh to offer key officials as
you are just laying out the from the
Trump Administration to on the briefings
on this PRC surveillance program uh and
so don't have we're not going to get
into the who are those key officials
from here I would refer you to the
intelligence community on those
Logistics on when it's going to happen
and uh who who those key officials are
would be but again we are we are
prepared we are willing to have that
conversation to do uh the briefing but
just not going to to get into the
specifics of who our third topic um
ready to put a VIP over the weekend
showed that majority of Democrats don't
want the president to seek re-election
they looking for new generation concerns
about his age without getting into
whether or not the president will will
announce does the president believe that
he has to address those concerns from
his own constituents so as you've just
laid out I'm going to be very careful
covered by the Hatch Act don't want to
get into uh the specifics of what 2024
is going to look like or any underlying
components of that the president has
been very clear he intends to run and
you know I think the way that we should
look at this is what we saw from the
midterms right I think that's a really
important uh point there where the
president laid out the policy right he's
the one that laid out the policy for
senators and Congressional members to to
really have a a midterms that did not
lead to a red wave right we saw what
happened in the Senate we saw that yes
Republicans now have Congress but by
slim majority we were told it was going
to be more than 60 seats and it's not
bad at all and that's because the
president went out there spoke directly
to the American people and laid out what
it is that we have done the last two
years how we've built you've heard from
Brian dies just moments ago he took many
many questions laying out the
president's economic plan how it's
working but how there's still more work
to do but essentially talking through
the different policies the different
policies that became that became
legislation that turned into law that
was that was historic and all of those
pieces matter and I think the State of
the Union he'll have an opportunity to
speak directly to the American people
not just congrat not just Congress to
talk about what we have done the last
what he has done the last two years and
how he sees the future of this country
and so I'm not going to get into what
the person what the President should
respond to I think uh you know the
president always says this watch him
watch him and see see what he does and I
think he has a record over the last two
years that shows that he has delivered
and that's the numbers that we're going
to pay attention to we're going to pay
attention to unemployment how it's been
down more than 53 years a historic
unemployment we're going to pay
attention to more than almost 12 million
jobs that has been created under this
President we're going to pay attention
to the 800 000 manufacturing jobs that
has been created under this President
and I think that's what we're going to
continue to work on and that's what
we're going to continue to speak to
thanks
um some State of the Union preparations
questions uh can you tell us what the
president was doing at Camp David this
weekend what did those preps look like
who is he working with is he still in
major rewrites at this point or just
kind of fine-tuning doing run-throughs
what was the weekend like for him so one
of the things that I said I said this
last week is that as you know when it
comes to Big speeches like this there's
going to be probably you know tweaks and
and uh to the speech until the last
minute that's kind of how how it goes
but I'll say more more generally or
actually speaking to your question about
Camp David the president was accompanied
by several of his senior aides work has
has gone into the speech over the course
of many many weeks as we know because
again this is something that the
president truly sees as a moment to
speak to the American people and the
work continued the weekend through the
weekend as uh as as it did today uh
Michael Donald Michael Donald was there
Bruce Reed was also there with him Steve
rashetti Anita Dunn and vinay ready as
you all know he is uh his uh his
speechwriter and so that was kind of the
makeup of the weekend and certainly not
going to get ahead of of anything else
from here and how does the president
which given the different dynamic in the
house chamber tomorrow night with the
Republican majority compared to his
speech last year you know this is a
republican majority that's launched
multiple investigations into his
administration how is he thinking of
that as he goes to give this speech
tomorrow night well as you know the
president is heavily as I've said many
times heavily engage in the writing
process when you when you hear the
speech you're certainly here there will
be no question that this is a Joe Biden
uh Joe Biden State of the Union speech
so just want to make that really clear
but you know don't want to get ahead of
what you're going to hear from him and
so again it's going to be about ensuring
our accomplishments and what we've done
the last two years he'll talk about that
clear clearly he'll lay that out and you
know and I've also said this before this
is a president that's incredibly
optimistic and he talks about the
possibilities he talks about not betting
against the American people and so
you'll continue to hear those types of
uh kind of uh themes in his in his
speech but of course I'm not going to
get into specific issues or the
political moment that we're in as he as
he's still working through and dealing
with the speech for tomorrow
[Music]
after the balloon was shot down there
were Communications between the
administration and their Chinese
counterparts and kind of detailing maybe
rationality why can you talk about how
you guys were thinking through the next
steps in this relationship given the
cancellation of secretary Clinton visit
but obviously it seemed to be a pretty
Brazen active in the course of the last
week so like our approach with China has
been pretty clear and we've been very um
very clear about this that and it will
be continue to be calm
Resolute and practical that is not going
to change on how we're going to move
forward with our relationship with China
with our diplomatic conversations as we
move Beyond this the president has been
clear we have been and will continue to
keep open lines of communications with
China as you mentioned uh blinken and
Jake Sullivan and many others have have
continued those those dialogues
especially after uh last week and in
fact uh he uh like as I was mentioned
there was multiple levels of a a
conversation about our about their
surveillance but balloon and again
communicated directly with China after
we took our action to bring the balloon
down so again multiple multiple channels
of communication that will continue
China's wee believes irresponsible
action were were visible for the
American and the world to see not only
that at the same time a second PRC
surveillance balloon was seen uh
traversing Latin Latin America that's
one thing that you all reported and it's
up to China to show it is serious about
its words of being a responsible country
that it wants to build a build on the
meeting that the president and uh
president XI very recently and so it's
up to China to figure out what kind of
relationship that they want and as you
know yes
secretary blinken did did postpone a his
trip it was not canceled and when the
time permits we'll see that trip back on
the books again it doesn't change our
what we are trying to do and how we're
trying to move with China it's up to
them
on Saturday when the president spoke try
to stop from Air Force One he seemed
very definitive and making clear that he
was the one who said explicitly I want
this to be shot down military leaders
suggested wait was that a reflection
perhaps in frustration in terms of the
political attacks you guys have gotten
from Republicans who said this should
have happened on the front end as
opposed to the back end well just a
couple of things I know there was a tick
tock that went out to all of you from
the National Security Council that was
pretty detailed on how everything kind
of broke down for the past week and how
things uh how things flowed I'll I'll
give a little truncated version of that
on Tuesday the president through the
National Security advisor Jake Sullivan
directed the military to refine and
present options to shoot the balloon
down immediately the President also
directed the military the intelligence
Community to collect against the
balloons so that we would learn more
about China's capabilities and
tradecraft at the same time we protected
we protected against Chinese
intelligence collection because we knew
exactly where the balloon was going the
military recommended taking the balloon
down over water following the
determination by military commanders
that there was undue risk of debris
causing harm to civilians while the
balloon was over land in Alaska Canada
or the continental United States on
Wednesday the president directed the
military to take it down at the first
available opportunity when it could be
done with safety especially as we're
thinking about Americans lives and being
safe there while maximizing our ability
to recover the payload shooting the
balloon down over water wasn't just the
safest option it maximized the chance of
recovering the payload giving us a
better chance to get information from
the Chinese surveillance balloon payload
but I think the bottom line here and
this is something that we want to make
very clear is that look what China did
was unacceptable we protected civilians
and we gained more Intel while
protecting our own sensitive information
and so I I laid that out so you have an
understanding of how this past week went
and you know the president as we all
know is not just the president he's also
the commander-in-chief and his number
one priority is making sure that
American lives are are protective and
that we protect uh you know citizens in
this country but at the same time we
wanted to make sure that we were able to
collect some data which we were able to
do and that's why we took that action
and the president the president made
sure we took that action face cream how
much damage has been done to the U.S
China relationship because of this and
expect the president to bring this topic
up in his speech tomorrow look I will
say this as we know when when it comes
to State of Union speech foreign policy
is always a topic in those in that
speech I'm not going to get ahead of the
president what he's going to to speak to
as it relates specifically to China you
know I just laid out at the top that it
is going to be up to China it's up to
China to see how they they want to see
this relationship moving forward and so
I'll leave it there let me ask you one
more broad question about the State of
the Union Address we heard Brian
Diesel's take on the economic terms
obviously foreign
being
can you just give us a broad brush
answer on what does President Biden hope
to achieve with the speech tomorrow
night
so you know and I've said this before so
it doesn't this doesn't change much at
all is that the president sees this
moment as a critical moment an important
moment to speak directly to the American
people to talk about the last two years
to talk about where we've been and where
we're going and that is important to the
present that doesn't change he's this is
the second state of the union speech
certainly not going to get into issues
and get ahead of the the president but
you know the president will underscore
the progress we have made during one of
the most challenging times
especially in history and the progress
the American people who want us to
continue to make by working together in
this year ahead you just you just heard
from Brian outline how the president has
carried out his economic Vision growing
the economy from the bottom up middle
out instead of the from the top the top
down one of the things that you have
seen this President do he has
transformed how we see the economy right
when you think about the trickle-down uh
did trickle-down economy he sees use it
again bottom up middle out this is
something that the president has done
with with the policies that has put
forward and so that is something that we
were going he's going you're going to
continue to hear from him continue to
hear from from him about giving the
American people a little bit more of a
breathing room uh it's because this is
something that he understands personally
so tomorrow is going to be a big
opportunity for the president again to
to speak directly to the American people
the millions of people who will be
watching and who will be wanting to hear
from their president and he takes this
incredibly seriously
um so I wonder if I could follow up a
little bit on on Zeke's third question
uh I think you made the assertion that
the reason that there wasn't a red wave
the reason that the elections in the
midterms were more successful than many
people thought they would be for
Democrats is because of the president
is that that's a fair yep and we've said
that before it's not it's nothing new we
think we we think the president played a
very big role in laying out the message
for Democrats so I wonder how in light
of the following poll you can make that
assertion this is a recent NBC poll
um is Biden honest and trustworthy 34
yes 48 no ability to handle a crisis 30
32 yes 49 no competent and effective 31
gas 49 though has the necessary mental
and physical health to be president 28
yes 54 though uniting the country 23 yes
50 no I mean
given that poll which you know is not
just a single poll it's been you know
versions of that have been repeated
in pull after poll survey after survey
since the midterm elections and before
and and I think one of my colleagues
referenced a recent poll that said 60
something percent more Democrats don't
want President Biden to be their nominee
then Republicans don't want president
Trump to be their nominee so given all
of that
why are you so convinced that it was
President Biden that caused the
Democratic success in the midterms and
not that the Democrats had success in
spite of the president well I'll say
this because if you look at what uh
candidates senators and Congressional
members ran on it was the successes that
the president had it was on the
bipartisan infrastructure legislation it
was on the chips and Science and science
act which was bipartisan because of the
president was able to make that happen
it was because of the inflation
reduction if you hear the message that
coming out of Democrats during the the
midterms it was what we were able to
deliver so yes and so that's what they
use right they used exactly what the
president was able to do in order to get
that success and so it is right if you
think about all of the pieces of of
historic legislation that became law
clearly that that we did last year again
the president LED that and the president
went out there and spoke on these uh
very important pieces of historic
legislation when you think about what
it's done for the economy what it's done
for the American people how it's
provided some relief yeah I think the
president did play a big role so they
just one quick follow-up I mean I mean I
guess does it suggest then that maybe
the Democrats who were talking about the
president's agenda have been more
successful at talking about the
president's agenda than the president
himself has been and does that make it
all the more important tomorrow and and
whatever whenever the president rolls
out his election really coming if he
does but does it make it that much more
important for the president to somehow
find a way to to communicate as
effectively as I guess some of these
other Democrats were because obviously
however however he's communicating Now
isn't translating so I'll say I mean
look I'll say this Michael and Brian and
Brian spoke to this right I think he got
this question every which way from from
your colleagues and uh a very important
question to ask but I'll say this we
understand and it is true that the
American people are feeling a feeling in
inflation they're feeling what the
pandemic and covet has has done right
the last two three years and so we
understand that they're going to have
some feelings about the economy right
now and so that is something that the
president has always acknowledged and
has said there's always more work to do
but also the reality is if you look at
the data if you look at how the economy
has bounced back because of this work
that the president has done and Brian
spoke to this I have spoke to this when
you think about Record 12 million jobs
when you think about unemployment limit
at the lowest it has been in 54 years
when you think about the 800 000
manufacturing jobs and how important the
chips and science Act is going to
continue to be as we see manufacturers
coming back to the U.S those are real
data points right those are real things
that has occurred these past two years
and it's because of the president and so
look we get where the American people
are but what we are going to focus on is
are the numbers that I just laid out and
that is also important will we continue
to need to talk direct to the American
people absolutely that's why the state
of the union we see it as an important
moment to lay out for the present to lay
out how he sees the country moving
forward and also to remind folks and lay
out what he has done the last two years
there's no easy answer there I get where
you're getting to but this is an
incredibly complicated time with the
president's going to focus on is how
he's going to continue to deliver for
the American people
foreign
[Music]
that the U.S identified flying over U.S
airspace under this Administration
um so what I can say is that
um we have talked about uh the China's
and China's balloon program uh we have
uh generally on this uh the Chinese
surveillance balloons program has been
around for some time we even we even
briefed Congress this past August so I
don't have any specific on any other
balloon during this during uh during
this president's Administration but
there has been a program that has been
in effect we have kept Congress abreast
on that so but I don't have anything
more to just to say or to share how is
it possible that this Administration
discovered at least three previous
balloons that flew over the U.S under
the previous administration but Trump
officials didn't know it was happening
yeah so look I think that and we have
talked about this before about how
when it when the PRC government
surveillance balloons trans uh trans
transited the continental U.S briefly at
least three times as you just mentioned
during the president's prior
Administration and once that we know of
the beginning of this administration's
but never for this duration of time as
we know this information was discovered
prior to the admin Administration left
but the intelligent Community as I said
is prepared to give give a briefings to
key officials but this is something this
is something sorry post so this is
something that we we they did not they
were not aware of as as we've just laid
out but again we are ready to brief key
officials to let them know what uh you
know what the intelligence committee was
able to figure out
I just don't did you go back and look at
some so I'm not going to get into
intelligence Community intelligence uh
Community information from here that's
not something that we do from the
certainly from The Briefing room what I
can say is that we learned of this the
three prior during the pass
Administration uh and uh and so we're
we're willing to share that information
but again just not going to get into
intelligence from here I have a question
on this since the administration was
aware of the Boolean program did any U.S
officials have conversations with the
Chinese about balloons over U.S airspace
Administration you know we're not going
to get into specifics of private
diplomatic conversations we have with
China we're just not going to do that
from here we've been very clear that
what China did was indeed a violation of
international law you've heard directly
from secretary blinken making that very
clear and China knows that it will that
we will vigorously defend our homeland
and sovereignty that is something that
we've also made very clear but we're
just not going to get into diplomatic
conversations from here
[Music]
is the president going to address the
yawning gap between vaccinations in the
developed world and in the less
development as you know I'm not going to
get ahead of the president's speech
tomorrow uh as it relates to kovid you
know the president has talked about uh
many times of how we've been able to get
the economy going and a lot of that was
because of how the president handled
covet of how he was able to push forward
an American Rescue plan that was able to
put forward a comprehensive plan to get
shots and arms and because of the work
that this president has done we are in a
different place covet is not taking over
our lives we're still fighting coven and
and but again we're in a different place
I'm just not going to get into what the
president's going to talk about or say
and on any particular issue we've kind
of given the Bro the you know kind of a
little bit of of uh a little bit of the
themes a little bit here you heard from
from Brian just not going to get ahead
of the president from here I'm gonna
okay
um sorry
um has the president looked at any
positivity and addresses for inspiration
as he crafts this one he's worked with
some great artists so many years so not
going to go into the into his process
what I can say is the president has been
was a Senator for 36 years he was vice
president for eight years he was has
been president for two he knows how this
process is he knows Works he knows uh
how important tomorrow is going to be
and he is when you hear the speech is
going to sound like a Joe Biden State of
the Union speech so I can definitely
assure you on that just not going to get
beyond that good the person behind you
thank you so Karine we know of these few
balloons that had flown in the past the
one of course from last week you say the
relationship is up to China going
forward should the expectation be for
the American public that that this is it
with balloons then or is it that this
could potentially happen again in the
future and if that's the case that the
standard procedure going forward is wait
for it to get over water and then it'll
be shot I'm not going to get into any
you know specifics of what might happen
next or hypotheticals from here I'm just
not going to do that what I can say is
as you've heard me say there is a there
was a China surveillance program right
balloon program that we have uh that has
been going on for some time that
Congress certainly was briefed on back
in late in last August but just just not
going to get into hypotheticals from
here and then one more um there are
there's bipartisan calls up on Capitol
Hill
as it relates to
[Music]
duplications of it you have Congressman
Ken Buck saying if you think of if you
see the CCP surveillance balloon scares
you wait until you hear about Tick Tock
Senator Michael Bennett had recently
called on the CEOs of Apple and Google
to remove tick tock from their uh from
their devices from their Google Play
stores and apple Play Store does the
administration believe that Tick Tock is
a national security threat and doesn't
believe that those apps should be
removed from from phones so look the
president of the Biden Administration
more more broadly has never allowed tick
tock on the White House devices other
federal agencies have similar
restriction we have been clear about our
concerns on apps like Tick Tock and so
look we are focused on the the
challenges of certain countries
including China seeking to leverage
digital Technologies in Americans data
in ways that present unaccountable
unacceptable National Security risk I'm
just not going to get ahead of it as we
know there's a review currently
happening uh but we take this very
seriously and as I said the Biden
Administration has never allowed to talk
on on the White House on the White House
devices
again I'm just not gonna there's a
review Happening by uh cepheus I'm just
not going to get ahead of that okay all
right thank you thank you so much